hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt hat es sollte ein ganz
schnelles rezept geben ich werde heute
pro skater machen aber jetzt nicht so
original italienisches eigentlich
überall gibt es in italienischen
restaurants sondern ich mache euch die
sally variante ich hab dir auch
irgendwann mal ganz kurz gezeigt vor
zwei oder drei jahren sogar in so einem
weihnachtsmenü aber weil mich viele oft
nachfragen habe ich geld kommt macht man
einzelne einzelnes video darüber und ich
zeigte
wir machen pro skater immer ganz gerne
wer als vorspeise oder so wie heute ich
bekomme heute noch besucht zum grillen
und da gibt es dann eben auch als
vorspeise beziehungsweise als beilage
hier habe ich jetzt schon mal das brot
gerichtet und es ist auch kein frisches
baguette als ihr könnt gerne auch ein
altes parkett nehme also sollten etwa
schimmel seiner reise es darf auch gern
eins zwei tage alt sein
das ist nicht schlimm weil es ja dann
gleich getröstet oder bzw gegrillt wird
im backofen
und das ist so eine kleine menge aber
ich habe ein bisserl nachschub ich mache
nämlich heute ganz viel platz 2 34
bleche ich weiß noch nicht genau
je nachdem wie hoch sich halt die meute
ist das gute bei prostata ist nämlich
ihr könnt es einfach auch schnell nach
bedarf noch mal nachmachen und habt es
dann einfach nicht rum stehen dann
brauche ich für die butter also ich mag
seine knoblauchbutter drüber da habe ich
jetzt zwei grip nach 10 60 gramm butter
ich brauch 40 milliliter olivenöl habe
hier einen halben teelöffel salz im
halben teelöffel basilikum ist genau
weil ich jetzt keinen frischen dahab
etwas chili ich noch etwas oregano und
dann habe ich hier für die tomaten
später 4 tomaten wobei ich es später
europa mehr nehmen ein esslöffel
balsamico-essig 1 esslöffel balsamico
creme das ist ein bisserl die dickere
variante wie karamellisiert ist so ein
bisschen ein gekochtes etwas salz und
natürlich auch noch pfeffer und oli
usw was jetzt zuerst macht ist das brot
zu schneiden
es war so dick wie ihr wollt ich mache
das immer so ungefähr cm dick könnte
auch zum beispiel der ehemann macher
lasse und ihr könnt dann in der zeit
schon mal die butter vorbereitet und bei
der butter ich halte es tolle ihr könnt
es halt vorbereiten und auch in den
kühlschrank stellen ich habe eigentlich
immer so ein glas voll meiner
knoblauchbutter im kühlschrank stehen
und wenn ich dann pro skater machen will
muss ich es einfach nur kurz raushole
und weich werden lassen kannst dann
einfach schon bestreichen und ich über
ergebnis ist einfach ganz kurz an den
mann
thomas von der anderen seite der
schlüssel eingetreten ist egal
während ute stop so toll macht werde ich
jetzt hier schon meine knoblauchbutter
zu bereiten
ich mache es jetzt in so einem kleinen
mixa aber das geht auch wenn ihr zum
beispiel den knoblauch einfach sein
würfelt geht es auch um sich richtig auf
koh samui ausprobiert ja das brot habe
ich aus szene nacht im freien stil
asenso tüte
dann kommt da die butter mit rein das
ist echt hartes brot aus dem steinofen
knoblauch und die gewürze tin whistle
oregano nehme ich jetzt noch
ich habe ja auch sehr bitter mit
abgeschöpft anständiges gestern
herrschte großer diesen alles sauber
ohne erde
ob wir vergessen
dann nämlich immer ganz gerne frische
treffer weil es einfach viel aromatisch
schmeckt
und wenn sich das dann alles verbunden
hat dann noch 40 milliliter olivenöl
dann haben wir die knoblauchbutter auch
gleich schon für das hoppala
es können mal reingucken leider könnt
ihr nicht rein riechen aber spricht halt
echt gut was ich noch gerne dazu gibt
oftmals ist paprikapulver denn das ist
ja schön rot und dann hat das eben brot
eben auch noch richtig tolle farbe
riecht sogar gefährlich hier ist china
jetzt danke schön nett von dir du musst
ja auch offen
genau das mache ich auch auf dem parkett
so dass du dahin nämlich auch anderes
brot wie das brot aber beide spielen
jetzt nimmt er einfach die brote und
könnte damit bestreichen und dann direkt
auf so ein backblech setzen
das kam jetzt auch zum beispiel schon
vorbereitet also das würde ich jetzt
auch mache bevor die gäste da sind und
dann wenn sie kommen muss ist ja nur für
ein paar minuten in den backofen und
dann kann man das ja kurz ein schiebe
und hatte als gleich das werde geprobt
und das geheimnis ist es nun ganz dünn
zu bestreichen
wer so schön das wohl zufällig und zu
lang break
normalerweise ist das so dass man das
brot einfach mit bisschen olivenöl
bestreichen dann einfach mit so einer
knoblauchzehe 1 reid oder drüber würfelt
ich finde es einfach langweilig finde
der chöre noch kräuter mitteilen
ich geb dir das jetzt auch kurz gleich
es macht auch meistens der murat bei uns
daheim also beim großvater bestreicht
studie untergang gestemmt
ich mache das feuer für den grill das
war's ach so der richtige mann kann mit
richtiger manischen mann mit seiner frau
diesmal ganz einfach zu sagen
und während dem rat jetzt noch die brote
bestreicht kann ich schon mal die
tomaten würfeln könnte das einfach mit
dem messer machen oder zum beispiel mit
dem alligator schneider
ich werde jetzt heute mit prozessor
machen auf der kitchenaid weil ich ja
später noch eine richtig große menge
macht und der zusammenbau auch ganz
einfach ich zeige es euch jetzt ganz
kurz weil ich habe viele anfragen oder
viele fragen wegen im food prozessor
wieder aufgesetzt werden gebraucht wird
im prinzip ist es total einfach muss er
nur daran gedreht werden und ich benutze
inhalt ganz gerne zum beispiel wetter
macht und die tomaten schönen würfel die
sind eher weich und das schafft er eben
oder wenn er zum beispiel einfach salate
auch macht obst salate oder man
ratatouille oder so wurde ich dann
einfach kurz raus und er würfelt das für
mich da brauche ich mit diesem würfel
absatz und das messer und das war's auch
schon
da muss man immer darauf achten auch
wenn das schloss wohnung geschlossen
und da muss man einfach darauf achtet
dass das hier auf diesem fall eben sitzt
dann kriegt man das auch direkt so mit
einem handgriff
ich stelle mir jetzt eine glasschüssel
runde da könnt ihr gleich durch sehen
die das raus gewürfelt wird
jetzt kann ich meine tomaten hier nehmen
sind bereits gewaschen
und weil die da oben jetzt nicht
reinpassen aber weil die passen würden
sogar rein passen aber ich halte sie
trotzdem
der aufsatz oder das team da oben ja
immer klein damit keine kinderhände
reinpassen
und da entferne ich kurz den strunk
man kann direkt statt
und jetzt habt ihr da oben meistens noch
was drin
wie kann ich euch das jetzt zeige ich
zeige euch das kurz zu teilen diesem
würfel aufsatz und es könnte jetzt ganz
einfach mit dem durchdrücken und meine
tomaten muss ich sagen waren extrem
weich als die waren wirklich sehr weit
deswegen wollte ich euch das jetzt auch
einfach mal zeigen dass viel saft
ausgetreten
aber das ist ja jetzt auch beim wetter
net schlimmer als wenn ihr so ein
bisschen fest auch tomaten habt tritt
auch nicht so viel saft aus aber ich bin
es nicht schlimm weil mir geht es eher
später drüber und ich mag das einfach
wenn dann das brot schön groß ist und
die tomaten dann so sind saftig jetzt
kann es einfach abdrehen und das
kunststoff nämlich jetzt hier raus und
kann es einfach in die spülmaschine
stecken und das einzige was ein wenig
schon die maschine ist natürlich das
große gestellt müsste einfach nur mit
einem sauberen lappen absitzen
aber das ist auch in der regel relativ
sauber war recht gefällig aber zuerst
kümmern
tomaten ich gebe jetzt hier nämlich
balsamico creme und balsamico essig mit
balsamico gehen nämlich immer ganz gern
weil es halt schön dickflüssig und eben
nicht so flüssig wie die noch mal mit
der normale balsamico ist mit ein
bisschen olivenöl eine prise zucker und
etwas salz und da auch gerne etwas
oregano oder basilikum
dann können das einfach verrühren
es stehe lasse ich werde jetzt das brot
kurz toasten und zwar kritisch ist jetzt
in dem backofen bei 200 grad so für etwa
fünf bis sechs minuten als wir nach dem
wichtig jedes auch habt müsste das
einfach länger oder kürzer packen und
ich gebe es bei mir fast ganz oben rein
also dass es schön von oben gegrillt
wird
mein vater ist jetzt aus dem oder das
brot aus dem backofen raus und jetzt
gebe ich hier noch wisse von den tomaten
dazu wobei ich mache immer so ich das so
dann auf dem tisch an und stellt es in
schälchen und gibt es mit der zug und
jeder darf sich dann selber tomaten und
soße drauf machen aber ich zeige euch
mal wie ich das immer solch ein
weiß ich kann mich doch jetzt vor der
kamera probieren soll ich glaube ich
mache mit weil ich versuche mich dann
sowieso nur das sehr gelassen
so richtet hier noch ein paar richtig
schön an und dann fertige mir die
gleiche moralische bremskräfte terrasse
wegen ist er so leise der macht mir
schon mal den grill an und die ersten
gäste schon da die karriere schon
und wir essen das jetzt gleich als
vorspeise und dann wird gleich gegrillt
und wenn ihr das jetzt nach dürfte das
rezept nachlesen auf cds blog.de
übrigens noch als kleinen tipp also ich
habe heute jetzt euch nur die einfache
menge gezeigt dass für ein backblech die
menge mit 60 computer und so weiter und
wenn ihr zum beispiel noch butter übrig
habt und eine riesenmenge macht könnte
auch zum beispiel brot so mit der butter
bestreichen den ofen geben wird es ein
klein scheidet können das sogar über im
salat übergeben also trance sind auch
richtig lecker müsste auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren und ich freue mich
natürlich darüber wenn ihm ein foto auf
instagram oder auf facebook schickt da
lade ich nämlich auch regelmäßig was
hoch und ich würde mal sagen wir lassen
es uns nicht schmecken
ein bisschen uns beim nächsten mal da
bis dann